welcome to hannity tonight in less than
24 hours democrats will put the work of
you the american people on hold
in order to carry out one last pointless
smear
of former president donald trump or as
jim acosta affectionately says
president trump in exile now instead of
working on covert relief instead of
creating jobs instead of getting aid to
front-line workers
or creating a plan to save so many small
businesses in trouble well congressional
democrats
they will be busy now for the
foreseeable future conducting
well so many agree is an
unconstitutional
impeachment charade show where the
verdict we all know is predetermined
former president trump will be acquitted
we know that 45 senators
have already voted to end the
impeachment trial
because it's not constitutional and by
the way the senate has no jurisdiction
over a private citizen
that would be donald trump nor can you
actually remove
a person from office that he no longer
holds
but it doesn't matter to the democrats
the media mob
they are living in their rage-filled
fantasy land it's like a drug they can't
give up their drug addiction
they claim that donald trump incited
this insurrection on january 6th
when he said things like oh fight like
hell
pretty much like every democrat like
we've been showing you for weeks
now apparently the mere use of hyperbole
that the democrats even use themselves
is grounds for impeachment but if that
new
standard if that's it for everybody
well then what are we going to do about
maxine waters she's going to have to be
impeached
you decide you see anybody
from that cabinet in a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you
[Applause]
the people are going to turn on them
they're going to protest
they're going to uh absolutely harass
them
until they decide that they're going to
tell the president
no i can't hang with you the line
president said that i had
threatened all of his constituents i did
not
threaten his constituents his supporters
i do that all the time but i didn't do
it that time
and with this kind of inspiration i will
go and take trump out tonight
[Applause]
i'm going to take trump out tonight as
you can see
for years maxine waters frequently
calling for harassment for violence
against the president
of the united states his staffers and
even his supporters she even talked
about taking him out
and using the democratic party's own
logic and standards
her insurrectionist incitement warrants
well that would warrant impeachment
right until now waters she's never faced
impeachment or punitive measures of any
kind in fact democrats
they even promoted her to be the
chairwoman of the powerful financial
services committee and that's because
according to her
waters herself she has done and said
absolutely nothing wrong whatsoever
trump insurrectionist hers is peace love
and kindness the type you'd hear
on a sunday morning in church take a
look
and they're going to try and say that we
have done rallies
and we've said things that have incited
others can you say that you have not
glorified or encouraged violence against
republicans
absolutely i can say it as a matter of
fact if you look at the words that i use
the strongest thing i said was tell them
they're not welcome
talk to them tell them they're not
welcome i didn't say go
and fight i didn't say anybody was going
to have any violence
and so they can't make that sting
create a crowd take trump out tonight
get in their faces
follow them into the grocery store
they're not wanted anywhere
anymore well we all heard the violent
rhetoric which according to the
democrats
own standards that is incitement towards
insurrection
we have tape and chuckie schumer
physically threatening two
u.s supreme court justices right there
on the steps of the u.s supreme court
building saying
they won't know what hit them and they
will pay the price
when is his impeachment trial start now
we heard
new jersey senator cory booker scream
go to the hill get up and please get up
in the face of these congress people
oh he's inciting insurrection we heard
joe biden
twice talk about yep taking trump behind
a gym and beating the hell
out of him i wonder if a conservative
said that about him what the reaction
would be
over the summer just days after a
minneapolis precinct burned to the
ground
violent riots freaking havoc multiple
cities
what did kamala harris say she well she
was encouraging more of it
telling stephen colbert they're not
going to stop
and everyone beware beware because
they're not going to stop
oh what burning down police precincts
they're not going to
stop before the election election day in
november they're not going to stop
after election day everyone you take
note
you take note of that on both levels
they're not going to let up
they should not and we should not sounds
like
insurrectionism anyway applying that
democratic standard
to waters and schumer and joe and kamala
harris and pelosi and others
also promoting by the way in harris's
case
promoting a bail fund to get violent
rioters arrested out of jail
okay i guess their impeachment trials
will follow
keep in mind according to nearly every
media mob outlet
now according to the fbi and
investigators now according to documents
in
that have been relayed to the court
court documents and even according to
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
the breach at the capitol oh it was
pre-planned
it wasn't some out of control
spontaneous incitement to riot because
of
donald trump's remarks in fact we're now
learning that the two
pipe bombs that we have on video that
were planted the night before
may have been part of a pre-organized
attack
so make no mistakes authorities were
warned about
an impending war at the capitol that was
being planned
perhaps weekended weeks in advance
this is why you don't have snap
impeachments
before you have any facts any
investigation any conclusion
never mind the idea that you might want
to allow the other side to
well at least make their case take a
look the investigation into the deadly
insurrection
at the u.s capitol a week ago new
evidence
that it was planned also shocking new
reporting that the fbi received a very
specific warning
before the riot that fbi notice warned
of
war at the capitol but for some reason
security wasn't stepped up there to meet
the challenge that that attack would
pose
that there was an fbi internal report
the day before the siege
warning of a violent war at the capitol
the fbi admitting that it had
intelligence before the insurrection
that people were planning to travel
to d.c with the intent to cause violence
now just how did president trump's
january six remarks and cite an attack
that has now been in the works for weeks
now tonight we need to get to the bottom
of what went wrong at the capitol this
can't happen in our country
and by the way those that traveled to
washington
d.c those involved in the plotting and
the planning and the scheming
with violent intentions oh yeah uh why
didn't we
know about it why weren't they prepared
and sadly democrats now are more
interested in just
waging yet another pointless smear of
former president in
exile donald trump and let's hope the
trial goes on and on for weeks and
months as a matter of fact i highly
recommend it chuck
just extend it out day after day week
after week
month after month let america fully
absorb how shallow you and your party
are
and let's all learn about the glaring
double standard
and the rank hypocrisy that is
all of washington and all of its swamp
ugliness
this is not never has been a serious
proceeding
it's a phony political show trial there
is no
judge chief justice roberts refused to
preside over the case
now you got that guy on the left side of
your screen
or right depending i guess the right
side of your screen on the left
facing this way democrat patrick leahy
he's going to preside
yup the same senator who's already
stated trump should be convicted
oh there's a fair and impartial uh
jurist right
now are we the only ones that see what a
complete farce
what a travesty of justice this is what
a total colossal waste of taxpayer money
and time
we also know where the so-called jury
stands
because nearly every senator has gone on
record with what their beliefs are
this is nothing more than a political
theater
the lines will be scripted they will be
delivered with great
passion it'll be like a broadway play
that you don't have to pay for
nor do you have to watch and we already
know how it ends
zero suspense what good is that so in
the coming days you can expect a lot of
manufactured
loud feigned phony outrage from
democrats in the media
how did this happen while ignoring
everything that the democrats have said
and done
over well even the last four years
none of it will mean a thing it's all an
act
from a bunch of swamp and sewer rat
politicians
who will never hold themselves
accountable to the very
standards they sanctimoniously set up
for
donald trump and others and of course of
mr unity
joe biden actually wanted to bring this
country together
as he says he does and actually ease
tensions
he could put a stop to this right now
there is an upside
the more they focus on hating president
trump well
frankly hold on to your wallets that
means less damage they're doing to the
country
by imposing their insane green new deal
socialist agenda and raising your taxes
and firing guys that work on the
keystone xl pipeline
and other pipelines and other oil and
energy exploration
and building the wall those guys that
got fired
keep going democrats you're doing a
great job helping americans
and while we're at it i have a long list
of witnesses frankly
i would like to see called and maybe
they should impeach him a few more times
let's maybe go for an even
dozen trump impeachments joe's never
going to stand up to the radicals
that control him he'll never ask for the
unity he says he wants
because he's incapable of standing up to
his own party
and the media mob that control him so
buckle up because this country is about
to be
put through hell over and over again and
guess what the democrats will scream
they will yell they will rant they will
rave they will
use their prepared scripts and throw
one last donald trump temper tantrum
all with the love of the media mob and
big tech
as my friend and colleague mark simone
radio host put it
tomorrow's impeachment day the democrats
impeach trump every february
it's now become an annual event kind of
like the golden globes
remember last february when they missed
the pandemic started
because they were focused on impeachment
too bad there's not a lot of
let's work for the american people day